I'd really don't want clothes on
majority the time it's really it's it's
tight in different places than you're
used to but I you know I am terrible at
cards I lose money every time I play I
don't mean to sound bull but what if I
told you your problems are over
eg Walker is a familiar face to hallmark
and yeah he looks a little like Captain
America
aka Chris Evans sometimes I do yes but
if we're being honest all the guys of
hallmark are pretty attractive and
romantic what is the most romantic thing
that you've done for your girlfriends I
decorated the apartment for us I don't
know that's not really romantic though I
don't know I don't you know what as soon
as I walk over there I'll think of
something really great so many romantic
things like flowers I'm sure there was a
nice surprise and a trip I know there's
a trip in there somewhere
have you ever stolen a scene from a
hallmark movie and done it in real life
absolutely not but that's a funny idea
and I think I will in the future I do
think about hallmark movies a lot
especially around Christmas of course so
I feel like probably most of my
Christmas behavior is informed by by
yeah have you ever stolen a storyline
from a hallmark movie and put it into
your real life I haven't because then my
wife would know I feel like Hallmark
steals storylines from my real life and
uses it on camera you guys watch them
together we do we do yeah and get this
we found out when they feel sexiest
you're welcome oh man I'm the most
self-deprecating human being on the face
of the planet so I'm gonna have the
least exciting answer for you ever and
say never when I'm on my motorcycle I
feel cool I don't know if I'm like a
honky but I feel cool on the motor
like I don't really ever feel that way
what I'm naked
if my girlfriend tells me I'm handsome
that'll make me feel good I am my best
self when I am adventuring when I do
something that could potentially risk
and bot risk bodily harm and I don't get
harmed I'm like I don't want any clothes
on I really don't want clothes on
majority of the time freedom freedom
these guys all have upcoming hallmark
projects on the horizon
Ryan's movie summer romance is out
August 17th howdy cowboy
what can you reveal what can you do I
can tell you that I have the coolest hat
I've ever worn and they let me keep it
and I wear it in my house sometimes for
literally no reason other than it
changes the way you walk it was awesome
she was super fun the word the the vibe
at the end of this one on set when we
all parted ways was that maybe we might
get to do it again but it was a charmed
project from day one so fingers crossed
we get to do it again Kevin McGarry has
a flick out November 27 and you'll
recognize him and Chris McNally from
when calls the heart season 7 premieres
next year would you like to get was
quite the love triangle situation there
was like a glance maybe whether I got
the glance she picked the other guy but
I got the glance that glanced mean to
you there might have been like a bit of
a connection I don't you wish you did I
think we'll find that out and see the 7
where do we think Elizabeth's heart is
really at probably with baby Jack I
think her eyes might be wandering
towards some guys but any girl hearts
with her baby you like your character is
ready to sort of be a father figure to
Jack
I think he's willing to yeah take
chances so be open today
RJ hot Tanaka has stars and that shows
spin-off when hope calls premiering
August 30th on hallmark movies now I'm
so excited yeah we've had a lot of
support from the fans and they're
amazing and yes I'm excited for people
to see it and see what we've been
working on it's a very romantic show
it's very passionate show how is it
wearing the Mountie costume I'm really
proud to be a part of it you know
the RCMP in Canada is very proud
traditions and Andrew and Jodie Sweetin
team up for a merry and bright out
November second she was amazing Jodie I
love you it's about a girl who inherits
a candy cane manufacturing company from
her grandparents it's going under and I
represent an investment firm that comes
in the day he and wife Cassandra are
also parents two four year old West with
another baby on the way
fifteen years is a long time what is the
secret the secret I wish I wish there
was a secret but I think it's this
communication she stays in her Lane I
try to stay in my lane and we just
communicate a lot does your son get who
dad is yets does he have a favorite
movie of yours it's funny because we
brought him for a check-up at his
pediatrician new pediatrician recently
and she asked him what he what both his
parents do he's kind of lose a little
confused for a bit and then said daddy
daddy plays daddy plays that's what he
said I'm like that's what I do buddy I
play I play exactly that's exactly what
I do and bonus fact Andrew can also sing
for sure I'll sing in a hallmark movie
for Michelle telling Michelle I'd like
to see
[Music]